Ben clears the air about all the
headlines and says I am who I am welcome
to Entertainment Tonight Michelle Turner
is off the two-time Oscar winner gets
candid about his box office bomb his ex
Jennifer Garner and yes his wife JLo and
let's start with that Meme worthy moment
that went down on Grammy night
I gotta go I gotta go all right I didn't
know they were rolling I leaned into her
and I was like as soon as they start
rolling I'm going to slide away from you
and leave you she goes you better
bleeping not leave despite giving all
these looks Affleck insisted he was
sober at the event but admits quote I've
gone to award shows and been drunk a
bunch and while Ben says he had a good
time he needed JLo to be his Grammy
guide I'm like all right who is this act
like I don't keep up my wife does
obviously
[Music]
healthy applix serving up resting Ben
face in this new photo shoot for a
Hollywood Reporter q a he's dressed down
and showing off his basketball moves to
promote his upcoming movie with pal Matt
Damon air got a name for it
Air Jordan
maybe it'll grow on me Ben confesses JLo
had to give him a last-minute
pre-interview pep talk quote she thinks
I've become very guarded and she's right
I view these things as landmines where
if you say one wrong thing your career
might be over so true Q Ben talking
about the other gen in his life we grew
apart we had a marriage that didn't work
part of why I started drinking alcoholic
was I was trapped Affleck labels the
headlines that followed ClickBank quote
I don't blame my ex-wife for my
alcoholism there have been so many
alcoholics who played alcoholics in the
history of the movie business the 50
year old also admits playing an addict
in the way back bombed a movie about a
guy gets divorced alcoholic nobody's
going to the theater to see this bleep
they're just not I felt it adding there
is still a tremendous stigma which is
often quite inhibiting he's called
working on this film therapeutic how set
there is a certain amount of therapy
that comes along with like emotional
honesty you know calling himself one of
the poster boys for actor alcoholism Ben
is proud fellow addicts have turned to
him to help in their recovery